but it seems like the female directors
are still there's a hindrance there and
that whole sort of percentage of women
moving up in their careers has not
followed with directing maybe so more so
with documentaries not narratives like
well I think it's surprising to me that
it's there more women producers than
directors and in fact the percentage of
women directors even in the directory
skill is appallingly low but I think
Kathryn Bigelow might have helped to to
change that somewhat and I think in
television there's a difference and it
just is a little perplexing to me why
why women roses producers a film more
than directors I would have thought it
would be the other way I don't know well
do you think in some sense and this is
going to sound strange but it's more of
a pink collar type of a thing producer
you're handling more details that might
be similar to a secretarial task no
where is no you don't think we're just
behind the camera and that's more well I
think the cult of the director has has
risen since the six east and that the
studios were complicit in it were you
know part of it so I mean it went as it
went and you know because prior to the
60s it was really the producers I mean a
lot of films you don't really remember
who the director was I think people
don't really know the director of Gone
with the Wind for example they think of
the producer or you think of a Samuel L
Goldwyn or of you know so anyway think
things have changed in terms of N and I
don't know I suppose for the better
because it has put more into the hands
of the more the more creative the
directors you know decisions but the
producers decisions are created to the
producer can you know be deciding the
location the cast the crew so at the end
of the day the director now gets credit
for all of that
it may well be the producer who put it
all together so I don't know how do you
think things will change or maybe they
want is this always going to be more of
an exclusive boys club do you think that
down the line as just gender roles have
changed I mean men are taking jobs as
stewards on airplanes and out of
necessity age is the economy turning and
you know men are staying home with the
children while women well I don't know
how it will be in the future but his
mother as a mother of two daughters I
would say it has not changed fast enough
so anything to fight those gender
stereotypes that you can think of
suppose you're on a set and you're asked
to go get people coffee and I know
you've said that no one really has a
role that's just exclusively theirs and
everybody pitches in but are there ways
to nicely or maybe not so nicely fight
those stereotypes well I think in a way
that you know society kind of gives
women somehow it creates an aura in
which they don't really know how to
propel themselves and they're not as
encouraged to do it as men are I think
men are you know as boys also a mother
of two boys and the boys are kind of
encouraged to you know to to win than to
you know to take charge into so in ways
that girls are not and some I'm racking
my brain to think of subtler examples
for which I can't but you know we've all
kind of experience look when I got
married my husband started using my
credit card so I called the credit card
company and said I'd like to increase
the amount that I could you know spend
every month because I'm married now and
my husband's using the card and they
said oh you're married oh well you can't
have a crowd
card in your own name then has to be in
your husband saying now that was just
something that everybody accepted
because that was just how it was I
didn't accept it it was just maybe a
little faster than the rest and I said
well if I don't have a credit card then
I'm not going to pay your bill so please
come after me because I just like to see
what happens and eventually I never paid
the bill and they would people would
call and say you need to pay the bill
and I say no I'd like to go to court
please sue me and then that never
happened and then eventually they called
every six months and then within a few
years the law changed but when you think
about it it was completely wrong and
that's you know that's in my lifetime so
anyway that's gone I do think that women
need to be encouraged more to put
themselves forward and to toot their own
horns and to you know go after what they
want and not think oh I won't be able to
do it but it's a little daunting to come
into a male-dominated arena and say you
know my turn but that's what has to be
done so
you